I'm joined today by Sarah Levin who's
the senior legislative associate for the
secular Coalition for America she
represents the organization on Capitol
Hill and in states across the country
lobbying to protect secular government
Sarah we've got a sort of a situation in
the United States where many people have
sort of the implicit understanding that
one of the parts of the deal for
churches being and religious
organizations being tax-exempt they
can't do politics and whether this means
lobbying for or against particular
candidates or issues as an issue of some
debate but I think many of us have that
general understanding and a lot of this
relates to something called the Johnson
amendment so maybe that's a good place
to start
what's the infrastructure that says hey
you can't do politics if you're a
tax-exempt religious organization
absolutely so I'm going to start by
defining a few terms because there's a
few things you have to kind of
understand before you understand what
the Johnson amendment is I'm going to
start by talking about a 501c3 nonprofit
so when from now and you know the rest
of the segment I'll be saying nonprofit
but I'm really referring to a specific
set 501c3 so think about your local soup
kitchen American Red Cross these are a
type of nonprofit that are subject to
the Johnson amendment and they're not
only tax-exempt but there's another very
special privilege that they have and
that is that when people donate to them
their donations are tax-deductible so
again think about you know when you
donate to your local soup kitchen to the
homeless shelter you can deduct that on
your taxes that's a pretty significant
incentive for people donate especially
for those who are donating in the
thousands or tens of thousands right so
that that specific those two privileges
come with strings attached and the
Johnson amendment which was passed in
1954 was actually introduced by Senator
Johnson before he was president Johnson
passed by Republican Congress signed by
a Republican president and it basically
prevents it prohibits 501 C 3 nonprofits
from endorsing or opposing political
candidates and otherwise intervening for
example giving money to to partisan
campaigns and it's important to
understand there are actually a lot
thinks III can do when it comes to
election so for example you can talk
about issues you could do a voter
education campaign you can say here's
where candidate Clinton stands on XY and
Z issue and here's where Trump stands on
XY and Z issue as long as your nonprofit
doesn't say vote for X candidate you
haven't broken the law as long as you're
not you know endorsing now one question
there just a jump in as a point of
clarity Sarah where would it fall within
these restrictions to say something like
here is the position of candidate a on
abortion here is the position of
candidate B on abortion the godly thing
to do is to generally speaking support
candidates with the following position
on that issue is that is that clearly on
one side of the line or the other it
definitely does blur the line but it
would probably pass to be honest as long
as it's if they didn't say so you should
vote for this candidate quite brilliant
in a sense then it is actually very
lenient um and so that's and that status
quo um but the what another thing you
have to understand so I understand why
the Religious Right is so interested in
this topic because of course the Johnson
amendment applies to all nonprofits but
how does the worship will just say
churches are a type of 501c3 nonprofit
and the they have a very special
privilege that all other nonprofits
don't pass and that is that they don't
have to file the same financial
disclosures to the IRS that all other
nonprofits do so for example especially
these big organizations a lot of them
just put what they call the form 990
that they have to submit to the IRS they
put it online so you can download it so
it's something that is available upon
request for everyday citizens so if you
want to decide if it's a good idea to
give to this nonprofit versus that
nonprofit you can go and look at their
form 990 s and see if they run their
organization with integrity you can see
the revenues expenses how much the CEO
is put paid that kind of stuff churches
are the only nonprofits that don't have
to file the full the full and complete
form 990 that's and that's again status
quo as
is so keeping all of that in mind what
will happen if the Johnson amendment is
repealed or or weakened or not enforced
and there's a lot of different attacks
coming from different sides and I'll
talk about that in a second or so is is
that numb it'll impact all nonprofits
and the integrity of the nonprofit
sector in general but it will
specifically open up for houses of
worship for churches a new dark hole for
campaign money to flow through because
if all of a sudden clergy can endorse or
oppose candidates more you know directly
from the pulpit and that's legal then
it's you can imagine if they don't have
to file any financial disclosure as it
is they could easily take donations and
donate to campaigns there will be
absolutely no trace there would be no
paper trail yeah so let's take this
through in a few component parts so
there's this 2018 financial services
general government appropriations bill
and it has a provision section 116 which
directs the IRS no longer to enforce the
Johnson amendment specifically for
houses of worship so that that to give
the audience one example you talk about
the weakening of the Johnson amendment
that's one example of how this could
happen let's say that that takes place
that that that goes through in section
116 is made part of that bill what can
churches now immediately do that they
previously could not do well first of
all I think it's important to note that
they're already violating the law openly
and getting away with it so it would
just c4 of that it will basically be
open season um they're the Alliance
defending freedom which is kind of like
the legal arm of the Christian Right has
been really leading the effort on
repealing or weakening the johnson them
and ever since 2008 they've been doing
an annual pulpit freedom Sunday where
they encourage clergy to endorse from
the pulpit tape themselves doing it and
send the tapes to the IRS so let's be
clear this is not being enforced as is
so basically what will happen is that
will get much worse these groups are
going to be much more brazen and
actually we've been lobbying with faith
communities about this issue because
there
opposed to changing the Johnson
amendment 89% of evangelical evangelical
pastors when asked if they think that
clergy should be endorsing to the pulpit
said no the majority of Americans of
faith across denominations oppose us why
because they don't want their churches
to be targeted you know it's very easy
for them if the local council person or
state legislature or federal legislature
running for office comes to the church
and say hey it'd be really great if you
endorse me for them to say well sir or
ma'am
that's illegal I'm not allowed to do
that once they can't see that any more
it's going to be very difficult to avoid
that kind of pressure both from
candidates and their own members and it
can really divide congregations there
are really meant to be a sacred a place
for worship so people of faith and
clergy don't want their churches to be
politicized so we're going to see more
of that we're going to see more of that
brazen behavior and what we're most
worried about is because there would be
little pretty much no accountability
whatsoever
is that financial dark hole for campaign
money to start flowing through
completely untraceable yeah and you know
I actually don't have a problem with
houses of worship doing politics as
someone who's non-religious myself I I
don't really care too much what houses
of worship are saying presuming that
it's not inciting violence or telling
telling people to go attack others or
commit crimes or whatever the case may
be I don't actually have a problem if
torches wanted to say hey we are going
to take political positions but they
should not be tax-exempt period if
that's the case and there's no way that
that's going to be rolled back any time
soon right I mean the thing is that the
501c3 status is a privilege it's not a
right and they can you know it's a
choice to if you want to say you know
we're going to be a church but we're
going to kind of you know forgo the C 3
status and and pay the taxes you know do
whatever you want you know that the
problem is that this is on the taxpayers
dime and the opposition is trying to
frame this as a free speech issue but
it's really not because when the
taxpayers are footing the bill there are
strings attached you can say whatever
you want on your own dime but not on the
taxpayers dime real quick Sarah what
other ways other than that sex
116 of the appropriations bill is the
Johnson amendment being attacked that's
a great question so there's a few bills
and that are kind of the section 116 as
you mentioned is a writer and a
proponent appropriations bill there's
also the free speech Fairness Act which
has two companion bills in the House and
the Senate and basically it would a
tweak it's not a straight repeal there's
another bill in the house that would be
a straight repeal just completely
striking the language altogether the
free speech Fairness Act weakens it by
allowing nonprofits to get involved in
endorsing politically and opposing
candidates and also spending a de
minimis amount of money on campaigns and
that just opens a whole you know can of
worms of what is de minimis because the
minimis means insubstantial well you
know if you're the university president
of a Notre Dame and you send an email to
the entire alumni network saying you
should vote for this person well that
didn't really cost you anything to press
the send button and on an email but you
certainly just helped that candidate a
whole lot yes not to mention that for
these gigantic mega churches there could
be an amount that's in substantial for
them based on their size and budget but
that in a relatively small race for
example could actually have a major
impact right absolutely so that's that's
one example of a weakening and that
really has more legs than another bill
which was a straight repeal because it
has a Senate companion has quite a few
co-sponsors and the house but right now
we're more worried about it being tagged
on to something big like an
appropriations bill yeah because this is
the kind of thing that it they want to
sneak in and they want it to fly onto
the radar all right Sarah Levin senior
legislative associate for the secular
Coalition of America for America we will
be following it and thanks so much for
talking to me about it today thanks so
much for having me